As people are trickling in,
my name is Keyvan Khashatri. I am the chair moderator of
this session, "Theranostics: The Nuts and Bolts."
This is the third time we have put on this
educational session,
and so I hope that you guys enjoy it.
It's something that we believe is important for this evolving field.
And so before getting started with the speakers,
I wanted to give just a short introduction to the session and kind of
our motivation as a group to try to push this field
forward.
So these are my disclosures.
So the purpose of this educational session,
again, has effectively learning objectives.
The learning objectives of this session that I hope that you gain from this is
really the ability to appreciate or describe the
advantages of theranostics as they apply to cancer research in the center of
cancer biology, to fundamentally develop
an ability to describe the components that make up
many of these radiopharmaceuticals,
the rationale for pairing radioisotopes with
a targeting mechanism or a targeting agent,
the ability to describe features of clinically approved radiopharmaceuticals.
And you'll get an appreciation, I think, of the clinical
translation of many of this now into now an FDA
approval. The indications that are approved for
many of these radiopharmaceutical therapy agents,
and really to be able to describe targets and
features of some new agents or new directions that could be
explored.
To give you just a quick history of the evolution of this field,
molecular imaging really paved the way, we believe, for theranostics.
Conventional medical imaging really focuses on anatomy, as many of you
know, and for detecting disease, directing
treatment. But molecular imaging provides this
mechanism to inform more than just the physical
structure, but maybe something about in vivo biology
that goes beyond these structural insights.
We can visualize things like therapeutic targets, cross
with things like total body PET, the whole body, and maybe guard things like
dosing. If you came to the session earlier today,
there was a great foray into dosimetry, for
example, by Delphine Chen.
So there has now been, and I would say in the last decade, a transformation from
molecular imaging to theranostics, and you can conceptualize
it as the same process as molecular imaging, at least the way you think
about making a molecular imaging probe.
But now in the setting of taking a target, identifying
it with molecular imaging, and then using that to guide the development of a
therapeutic radioligand on maybe that same target or an
analogous target, and that then becomes a therapy, a drug.
And I think we're now at the stages of many successful clinical trials, FDA
approval, and then now to go back and refine this platform of drugs
to be more effective.
There are a number of interesting recent clinical trials, which we'll hear
more about in the context of Jonathan
McConathy's talk.
But this evolution, I would say in the last 13 years, from radium to
lutetium to now lutetium PSMA and the FDA
approval of these and some series of landmark trials that I think
define why everyone's so excited about this field.
The landscape of theranostics is now broader.
This is a great figure that was provided to us by Shivang
Berk. And I think in this description, I just want you to
appreciate the scale and the breadth of now
ligands, targets,
isotopes, and kind of just the dimensionality
of this field, which I feel like has exploded in the last maybe
five to 10 years. We as a
community want to bring these groups together,
both the molecular imaging field, cancer biologists, chemists,
physicists, with industrial partners, with the
government, to really try to bring a community together to
engage the next generation of development in the space because we're excited about
them potentially yielding cures for cancer patients.
And so as a result of that, many years ago, we got together to
establish a task force. This series of
educational sessions, as well as a number of scientific sessions,
are the product of this task force.
The goal of this AACR task force we call CMIT was meant to
actually address this unmet need in the field where many people were
developing new, interesting chemistries and physics
and treatments, but maybe in a disjoint way from the cancer biology
community, which we believe AACR truly encapsulates.
And so the mission was really to accelerate the development of this field and the
expansion by bringing these people together in this kind of
task force sponsored by AACR. Now, through various
programs, we hope that this will foster new research in
molecular imaging, maybe a better understanding of biological mechanisms that
drive response to these treatments, like radioligand therapy that we're developing,
and then basically a forum to create that, and you all are now part
of this forum.
The task force actually is broad. It's diverse.
It covers many members that are included across not just
the US, but of course internationally, and not just in classical
radiochemistry, but clinical translation and fields of cancer biology to think
about things like treatment response, as well as industrial partners that are
interested in trying to take these platforms forward
to really expand them to help patients.Now, one
of the major
upcoming activities as a result of like our task force is actually
a series of sessions at this meeting.
One, of course, that you're in currently, but there is also a scientific
session on
next generation radioligand therapy. I just put the information there since it is.
And then as well as another session on radioligand therapy and the immune
system and biological mechanisms, which is happening just a
couple of days after. So please check these sessions out.
We believe that these great speakers that come to these sessions will
illuminate the directions that we hope the science is going in.
And then I think the other thing that we're most excited about is that over the
last couple of years and the success of these sessions and you as a community being
interested in this space, it has allowed us the ability to convince the
AACR leadership to allow us to hold a cancer
biology informed targeted specific AACR conference
that will happen
in San Diego in January of next year.
This is the initial first announcement.
There will be a number of other announcements, hopefully throughout the meeting,
and also
some released publications that will go along with it, hopefully in the
next couple of months in AACR journal.
So if you're interested, there is a QR code.
I'm going to put this slide back up after the speakers
so that you'll also be able to get this information later.
Now, with that said, I just want to introduce you to the two
speakers who will lead this session. The first is Dr.
Kathy Cutler. She is an expert in isotope
research. She's at Brookhaven National Lab, and I think she will
provide you with the educational background to be able to fully
understand radiochemistry and isotopes, and hopefully illuminate maybe a direction
toward how you could develop some of these in the setting of novel
targets in the future. And then the second is Dr.
Jonathan McConathy. He's coming to us from the University of Alabama.
He is an expert not just in developing new molecules, but translating them
to humans. And I think he can give you a perspective on doing this
translation and taking it into people, and what questions you would like to answer
So our goal is to have
both Dr. Cutler and Dr. McConathy speak.
We'll hold the questions after their lectures to the
end, and then we'll have a round table discussion at the end.
If you've been to this session before, we tend to have that at the end, and please
feel free to ask any of those questions in the round table.
So with that, I am going to hand it
over to Kathy.
Do I find the top?
You should.
Okay. Thank you.
So, thank you. I'm going to talk to you a little about some of the things that
you need to consider for
producing and really using an isotope in
radiotheranostics. So, and notice I use
the G because
I think that helps point out that the imaging part is as important
as a therapeutic.
So, I have really no financial professional disclosures, and
my background is in inorganic chemistry, and
I've used a variety of methods for actually producing
radioisotopes. And I am the immediate past president of the SNMMI.
So, as it was kind of stated earlier, we're at a time,
I remember when I graduated,
got my degree, there was almost no jobs in the field, and it looked like the
field was going down the tubes. And we're in a very different situation
now because really of theranostics, particularly in
oncology, but also in neurology
and cardiology. And we're seeing that companies are
spending billions of dollars trying to develop new drugs or
take on drugs and getting them through clinical trials.
And so it's a really exciting time, and we're expecting that in the next
10 years, the field will double or even triple as we're moving
forward. And this is causing some challenges as
we try to figure out how we can handle that.
And one thing of that is really on the isotope supply that we
have. Now, the US is not unique. Many
countries are highly reliant on supply that's outside of the
country, and that's actually true for the US.
We have about 30 different medical isotopes that we actually bring into the
US and we use. And the three most prominent ones are
Molybdenum-99, which is used for technetium production.
For therapy, it's Iodine-131, and Lutetium-177.
And these are reactor-produced isotopes, and there's about six
reactors in the world that actually produce these.
And they were originally built to last for about 20 years, and many of them are now
been operating for 60 years. And the challenge gets to be
is maintenance sometimes results in them being shut
down, which leads to shortages that we have.
The good thing is that there's a lot of interest now in
building new reactors, and we're seeing that there are plans in place
to replace some of these reactors.
And there's actually plans in the US to actually build new reactors.
The University of Missouri is looking, Eden Isotopes.
So this is really looking like it's going to turn
around.The other challenge that we've really had is reimbursement
complications. And part of this is that when MOLLI was made,
MOLLI was something that was produced at reactors, and it was kind of made
for the good of mankind and not as an economic
viable model. And companies were really making their money off of the
kits that they sold and not really the generators.
And so this really became a problem when we started having shortages,
and we started looking at the economic model, realizing that we really
weren't charging enough for this to be viable.
So we're really trying to ensure going forward that we have an
economic model for supporting the isotope production to make
sure it's there, but also for supporting the field.
We've been predominantly an imaging field, but now we're moving into doing
theranostics, which really changes how we deliver this, and we need to
make sure that we have sustainable reimbursement for the teams that are
actually doing this work.
And then the regulatory issues. So we are largely regulated by the
FDA and the NRC, and the isotopes and what
we're doing is fairly new to them. So we really have to engage with them to
make sure that the regulations that they're putting in place are not really going
to mitigate patient access as we move forward.
Transportation, we're making isotopes that have very short half-lives,
and we want to make sure that the shipments don't get delayed because someone's not
happy with the paperwork or the pilot doesn't want it on their
plane or that the package gets left in Indianapolis.
And so we're really trying to work on trying to find actually new ways that we can
market,
actually label these packages, and this is an international thing
so that people will understand that these are for medical use and that if you
delay this, this really means that some patient isn't getting their treatment
going forward. And then workforce pipeline.
So we're at a point where the field is rapidly growing and industry is
rapidly growing, and they're really sucking up a lot of talent.
And so we're having a challenge really meeting the need.
At the same time, we did a survey a few years ago, and we realized that about
30% of the people who work in this field are going to be
retiring in the next 10 years, which is another
concern. And then all this on top of we have
geopolitical
issues that are ongoing and some of the isotopes that we need are
produced in countries in which sanctions are on or they're closing
off the pathways in which ships come through.
And so we have to be concerned about that.
So there's really been a huge push to try to have a diversity
actually in the supply of these isotopes.
So theranostic is not something new.
It's something that we've really been practicing a long time through
iodine-131 and traditionally, but it really changed when we
started bringing on agents, particularly with lutetium-177 and
radium-223. These really changed the quality of life for
patients and helped extend life
instead of just palliating, which some of the other treatments were used
for. The other thing is that compassionate use programs have allowed
us to look at things like alpha emitters in patients who have had no
options, and we've really kind of seen the benefit of what they
can do for these patients. And this has really driven a lot of research
into this. The challenge is that these new novel isotopes,
particularly the alpha emitters, the alpha emitters have traditionally been
harvested from waste that we developed back when we were developing the
Manhattan Project. And a lot of that waste is now gone.
So we've had to come up with new ways to actually produce those isotopes,
and it's not a trivial process. And so
there's targets that we use that emit gases
that we have to worry about. Radium-226 is not readily
available. There's waste issues.
There's just a number of things that we've had to address to really
make these viable. That being said, there's
now a lot of industry that's very interested in making this.
And now what we're seeing is industry is coming on board with
new ways to produce these and actually bringing these in
using things like rotatrons and things like that to make them more readily
available. So in the future, we're hoping to see that we'll have a
more sustainable supply that will actually meet the demand.
So as we're going through this, some of the challenges that we're
having is we have a large number of early-stage projects.
If you saw the slide that Kevin showed earlier, you see all
these new agents that are going into the pipeline.
And many of these are by large pharma or small companies who are very
new to the field of radiopharmaceutical.
And we need to make sure that we educate them about what
is needed as we actually go through this.
So it's very promising in that a lot of money is being spent and we have great
opportunities, but we also have to look at some of the
limitations. So some of that is that we need to make sure that we have
enough of the therapeutic radionuclides for the manufacturing supply.
And so keep in mind, when we're doing therapy, we're using 10 to
20 times more of the isotope, and we're normally delivering at four to six
times. So that's a huge amount that we need to make.
And these agents now have additional challenges that we
need to go through when we're thinking about how to handle them in the clinic,
the chemistry when you have that much radioactivity, and then the pharmacy
expertise to actually bring them forward.
And what we're seeing is that we're seeing that this is new to the
FDA. And so we're having to work with them to understand these new
isotopes and what the regulations are that we're putting in
place. And we're working with the USP to try to develop new
chapters. So there's a lot we need to do to make
sure that as we see different production and
manufacturing come online, that we put in regulations that can
actually accommodate both for industry and academia as
well as industry as we move
forward.Now, as we look at this, this is
from a paper that came out from "The Lancet" Commission on
theranostics. And just to kind of show you, this paper kind of went
through and it listed various radionuclides and what they could be used for and
how you could actually produce them.
And it also showed the location of
reactors throughout the world. And where you want to be is really in that dark
green area on the map, because that's where they have the most reactors.
And you can see in the US, where we use 50% of
all the radionuclides, we really have the lowest number of
reactors in the world. And this is what really creates the
challenge and why we're bringing so many things actually in.
And what you can see is that Europe is in a pretty good place, but Asia in
particularly, has a large number of reactors, and they're bringing on
many new.
Now if you look at cyclotrons, which is the other way we make
radioisotopes, you can see we're in a bit better place there.
We're green. We're not dark green, but at least we're in the green
here. And again, you can see that Europe is doing really well.
But again, you see that Asia really has predominant
infrastructure in this area. And this is one reason why Asia is really
predicted to really grow as we move forward.
But we really need the infrastructure to basically produce these
isotopes. So when we're looking at isotopes and
which ones we want to use, we need to look at the mode of decay,
so what
is given off by the decay, the half-life, because we want the
half-life to match the biological half-life of the agent.
We want it to be very pure and to have a good specific activity.
It's important for it to be available.
There are many isotopes that would be great to use, but we can't make it in
significant quantities, so there's really no point in going down
there. And then we need it to have high quality, and we
want it to be at a reasonable cost.
And then for radiolabeling, we like it to be simple, it needs to
be stable, and we want it to have ideal pharmacokinetics.
So ideally, it would go to the tumor, and anything that doesn't is going to clear
out very quickly.
So most of the types of things that we're looking at for
therapy, we want things that emit particles.
So we're looking at alpha particles,
beta particles, which are electrons, and for imaging, we're looking at
positrons, which annihilate to give off the two 511 KeVs.
And then for SPECT, we want basically a photon that is emitted.
Now, for diagnosis, the ideal is that we want to image, and particularly in
theranostics, we're trying to determine if the target is there.
And if we have enough of the agent taken up at the target that we can actually
go forward and do therapy. And we want to use it for dosimetry,
which I understand was talked about earlier, and then we want to use it to
understand the pharmacokinetics, particularly as we move forward in clinical
trials to inform the doses and to inform that that
patient is still moving as we go forward, and we want it to have such
an emission that it actually external from the body.
For therapy, we want to use particle emitters.
Most prominently has been used is beta particles, and
that's due to the fact that they're the ones largely produced.
But there's been a lot of work looking at alpha particles and Auger
electrons.
So the one thing we need to really look at
is making sure that we match the half-life to the uptake and the
clearance of the agent. And I had a talk one time
with a university talking about different radionuclides.
And the person basically said to me, "Well, I can use carbon-11 for
everything." And I was like, "Well, actually you can't, because if
you're using an antibody that's going to take a long time to be taken up, the
amount of carbon-11 you would have to inject into that patient would be
quite toxic." So you really need something that has a long half-life that's
going to allow you to get there to actually use it.
And then most of the time we're making these, and we have to ship them somewhere
else, particularly for therapy. So it needs to have a long enough half-life
so we can actually do that transport.
The specific activity, we usually want it to be high, but we have
seen cases where if it's too high, then we see a lot of normal tissue
uptake. So we have to make sure that
it matches what we need for that agent, and we have to look at what the production
and how we actually make that target material.
The chemistry, we'd like it to be fairly easy and straightforward.
I actually started out as a technetium rhenium chemistry, and
technetium and rhenium have a lot of different oxidation states, and so it's very
difficult to get one agent. You can get a lot, but it takes a lot of work
to optimize it. So there's been a lot of work-- Let me see. Can I go back?
Really looking at trying to use radiometals where you can just do a simple
complex through a chelate and get a simple agent.
But then you also have to worry about the in vivo clearance of these
agents. And one of the nice things about rhenium-186
is that if it goes to normal targets, it actually gets
oxidized up to prenate, which then washes out very quickly from the
kidney. So it really lowers that normal
organ uptake. But the chemistry also affects the
separation and purification. And sometimes, like for instance,
we're making actinium-225 through distillation.
We have to separate that from four other isotopes, which can be
rather complicated to do.
Now, the other thing you want to look at is the range that these particles actually
travel. And so the big circle here, what you're seeing is this is kind
of a demonstration of a range of a beta particle.
And beta particles can travel long ranges.
And for large tumors, this can be fairly ideal because you can get the
crossfire, and you don't necessarily have to target every tumor.
But if you're looking at small metastases, what can happen is that beta particle
can leave that small metastasis, and the dose is going to go to that
normal tissue. And that normal tissue toxicity is then going to
lower the amount of activity that you can deliver, which is going to lower the
overall efficacy of that drug. So you can look at other things
such as alpha particles, which are shown in the red on here,
and you can see that this travels a very short distance.So all of the
dose then gets retained into that small metastasis,
and you're going to see very minimal toxicity to normal tissues.
And we also see this for conversion electrons, which is actually shown in the
yellow. So the range gets really important in actually
choosing the radionuclide for the disease that you're looking at.
Now, most time for radionuclides, they don't necessarily go where we want
to just by injection. There are some that are iodine-131,
strontium-89, but many others we have to come up with, quote, "a
mechanism of delivery." How do we keep it where we want it to
go? And so some of these we use like seeds or particles, and this is
used particularly for treating prostate cancer.
We use chemistry to actually develop small molecules to give them
properties. For instance, we use phosphonate compounds to get agents to
go to bone cancer for palliation, or we can use molecular
targeting agents. So we have agents that target receptors that
are overexpressed, and we can attach the radionuclide, and it kind
of behaves kind of as a taxi cab and takes it to the agent.
And there's been a lot of interest in actually using nanoparticles because we can
tend to increase the dose and use the ER effect to get these
taken in.
So for the targeted approach, which is the largest that has been used for
theranostics, you have a targeting vector, normally a
peptide, a monoclonal antibody, or a hormone.
And to that, you attach your radiometal through what's called a bifunctional
chelating agent. And this is normally an agent that stably binds
that metal to go in vivo. You then have a
linker that attaches the bifunctional chelator to the
targeting vector. And that linker can become very important because
it needs to ensure that that metal bifunctional chelator does
not interfere with the affinity of your targeting vector.
But you can also modify that to modify some of the pharmacodynamics of
what's going on in vivo.
So here's just a list of some of the common
therapeutic isotopes that I've been looking at and also some of the new ones that
are coming up. Iodine-131. We have
iodine-124 and 123 that we can use for imaging.
And then yttrium-90. And when I started in the field, it was thought that you could
do everything with iodine-131 and yttrium-90.
And then they started doing trials with yttrium-90, and what they found is some of
the normal tissue toxicity was too high, so they needed to look for other agents.
And so that's when we started looking at lutetium-177 because it had a
lower range beta particle, and that lowered particularly the overall
kidney toxicity. But these are plus three metals, and there are many
plus three imaging agents that we can actually use to image these.
And then you have rhenium-technetium.
There's bromine, which there's a lot of work, and then the copper isotopes,
copper-67 for therapy, and then copper-64 for imaging.
And then here are some of the novel ones that are coming up that people are looking
at. Scandium-47, which has properties similar to lutetium,
and then scandium-44 and 43, which can be made on a
cyclotron. Actinium-225, which is an alpha emitter,
and then there are a number of different imaging agents for that.
Arsenic-77 is a longer-lived isotope which has
been used for antibodies.
Terbium-161, which has conversion electrons and has been
shown to deliver higher doses than lutetium.
Thorium-227 and lead-212, which were both alpha emitters,
which there's a lot of interest in.
So when we're looking at these isotope pairs and we're trying to choose
which ones we want to use, it's best if we have matched
pairs. And if we don't have matched pairs, a challenge can be is that the
chemistry can be different, and that chemistry can impact
the overall uptake of those agents.
And we can see differences in biology.
So we can see differences in uptake in the tumor versus the
normal tissue, and that can impact the choices that we
make. We often see varying half-lives.
The imaging surrogate normally has a shorter half-life, and the question is:
Do you need it longer? For your pre-clinical trials, you might want to have a
longer imaging agent so you can really understand what happens.
So you need to kind of determine what you can have.
And then it's important that it's available so that as you enter pre-clinical
trials, it's actually there.
Now, one of the
standards that has really been used to compare a lot of different radionuclides
is somatostatin. And so octreotide is a
modified somatostatin analog. It was modified with D-amino
acids because it had a really short half-life.
It normally lasts about three minutes if you inject it in vivo.
So by adding in the D-amino acids, this made it have a much longer
half-life,
and it has a very high affinity for somatostatin
2 and actually somatostatin 5. So you can use those for
imaging and treating neuroendocrine tumors.
I was just at the TAP meeting, and people are now using it for doing breast cancer
as well. But it was originally designed as a chemotherapeutic.
So when we're using these peptides, what we need to do is to attach
chelators to actually bind these radiometals.
And these are
not all-encompassing,
but these are some common chelators that are used.
EDTA and DTPA for indium-111, bismuth-213,
and DOTA has been considered the all-encompassing chelator
because you can bind a variety of different chelators.
And then TETA was initially actually used
for copper.
So the somatostatin ligand, Helmut Macken attached a
DOTA chelator because he wanted to basically use this for
therapy.And what he did is he looked at a variety of plus
three radiometals for doing both imaging and therapy.
So he initially looked at yttrium-90, and then he looked at
indium-111 and gallium-68 for really doing
some of the imaging. And at the time, these are plus three metals, and it was
basically felt that you weren't going to see any real difference.
But it turned out that we saw major differences when we went in vivo.
And so here the white is the indium DTPA
TreaScan, which is quite different, but it's a different chelator.
But when you look at the indium-111 DOTATOC and
yttrium-90, they're fairly close.
But when you look at the gallium-67, you see
much higher uptake in the tumor, and it also turned out you had much
more clearance in normal tissues.
And this is because the gallium is a six coordinate compound and has an extra
negative charge, and this extra negative charge is what's causing the higher
uptake. So if you're looking at this to try to understand the uptake of
yttrium-90, you have to be very careful because it's going to overestimate
what goes to the tumor and kind of underestimate what goes to the normal
tissues.
Here you can see an image of the indium DTPA and the
gallium-68, and you can see the gallium-68 is a PET
emitter, a positron emitter, and you can see that you have much higher
resolution, and this is what really led to this being approved and
being commonly used today.
Now, there was a lot of interest in using copper-64.
Some of the challenges with copper-64 and copper-67 was really their
initial production, which was via reactor and via high
energy protons, and we just couldn't make enough.
The DeNardos were trying to use copper-67 because it seemed fairly ideal for
metastatic disease.
But we've now got copper-64 that we can routinely produce in our
cyclotrons, and copper-67 can be made by
rotatrons, which through the photonuclear route.
And the group in Australia used what are called Sargent's and ligands, and these
are ligands that tightly bind the copper chelator.
And what you can see here is that when you look at the copper-64, you
have very high uptake in the tumor and you have fast
clearance through the liver. If you use DOTA, it turns out that the copper
is reduced, and you have uptake in the liver.
If you look at the copper-67 compared to lutetium, you see that
the uptake is very similar.
Now, the nice thing about this is that you can use the copper-64 to image
patients, determine that they're positive, that they have low uptake in normal
tissues. You can then go on and use the copper-67, and the
copper-67 has a spec photon that you can image.
And here you can see that they actually line up very well.
So this is really an ideal matched pair.
There are other matched pairs. Lead-212 is an
agent that decays giving off an alpha emitter, bismuth-212, and there's a
lot of interest in using this.
This is an agent that's being developed by Perspective, and it's
an agent, again, for neuroendocrine tumors.
And you can use lead-203, which can be made on a cyclotron for actually
doing the SPECT imaging. And so this gives you a good ideal, and it's
fairly great for doing preclinical trials or
clinical trials. And here you can see some of the images that were done at one,
four, and 18 hours.
And then finally, scandium-47 and scandium-44.
Scandium-47 is similar to lutetium, but it does have a
photon that you can image that's very similar to
technetium-99m, so ideal for SPECT cameras.
And then scandium-44 is a short-lived positron emitter that
can be made on cyclotrons but also via a generator.
And this is some work that was actually done at PSI, in which they looked
at, again, a
somatostatin analog that targets.
And here in A, you see the uptake of the
SPECT, and in B, you see the positron emitter, and you can see that they
match very well.
So in conclusion, we've had a lot of research and development that is
ongoing. We have a lot of new radionuclides, which
help as we have these new agents and allow us to really do precision
medicine. We have a lot of work that's ongoing, which is
really offering patients the opportunity.
Economically, radionuclides are now in a position where industry is
stepping in and supplying them, which is getting us to the point that we
can actually support the clinical trials and then hopefully
further drug development in the future.
And on that note, I thank you.
Thanks so much, Cathy.
We're just going to hold the questions until after the next talk as well as the
online one. So if you're online and you're wondering why we're not asking, that's
why.
Great.
So thanks, Cathy, for a great talk.
I'm going to shift gears a little bit and look more at the application side.
And in this talk, I'm going to focus on what we're using now in the
clinic and agents and types
of trials and treatments that are likely to be in the near future.
I was expecting a disclosure slide to show.
My disclosures are online, but the one that's really relevant to this talk is I do
consulting and have some research support from Novartis, who makes two of the
drugs, the dotatate and PSMA therapies I'll be talking about.
I'll also be talking about some investigational agents that are not in routine
clinical use, and I'll try to make it very clear when we're talking about things
we do routinely, clinically, that are FDA approved and those that are
investigational.So this is kind of a similar schematic to what
Kathy showed. When I think of theranostics, I think about some sort of
pharmacologically active portion that delivers the
drug where you want it to go, maybe clears it from where you don't want it,
linked to radioactivity. And really you do need to think of the
entire radiopharmaceutical or radiotheranostic as
a whole, because the chelator, the linker, or the
metal can affect what you see. I'm agnostic
to whether we should have a G in it. I like to say theranostic without the G.
I think both are fine. Why are these exciting?
Radiation has been a cornerstone of cancer therapy for a long time.
And a lot of it's delivered externally, but by using radiopharmaceuticals, we
can go after targets on the tumor cells
themselves or in the microenvironment to more selectively
give radiation therapy. Additionally, we can deliver it throughout the entire
body, which is an advantage over external beam radiation
therapy for people with metastatic disease.
Additionally, the ability to image
beforehand and see if the target's there in sufficient
quantities before treating is something that's very important clinically,
and it's also important for clinical trials.
And I'm not going to discuss it much, but more and more companies and
agent developers are using this property to decide which
of a class of therapeutics, which molecule is most promising.
And really importantly for imaging, we can look at the entire metastatic
burden. We're not
subject to some of the sampling errors that you can have with
biopsy. And finally, like other drugs, we
can be used in combination. And I think that's one of the areas where
we're going to see a lot of growth is radiopharmaceuticals in conjunction and
combination with other therapies.
So I agree, somatostatin receptor ligands like dotatate are great
examples. So here we have the targeting part of a somatostatin
receptor ligand and the DOTA chelator.
If we use gallium-68 or copper-64, we have nice PET
imaging compounds.
If we switch this out for lutetium or other radiometals with therapeutic
properties, the same molecule is now a
therapy. So I'm going to quick quiz.
Patient one, patient two, both have metastatic neuroendocrine tumors.
We're looking at their CTs, which one should get
dotatate therapy?
And you don't know the answer.
We can see these metastases in the liver, but one of the
concepts that I think is really changing in the era of theranostics is we're often
doing imaging not to see whether a patient has cancer
or stage it, although those remain very important.
We're really doing this to biologically characterize the tumor to make treatment
decisions. So those who guessed patient two were correct.
Patient two has a lot of somatostatin receptor expression seen with
dotatate PET, whereas there is some in patient one's
metastases, but much lower with some mets really having
barely higher uptake than liver. And if we look at these maximum
intensity projection images, which allow us to look at the PET, and throughout the
whole body, you can see in patient one, actually some of the retroperitoneal lymph
nodes have a lot of somatostatin receptor expression, whereas the
liver metastases don't, and this patient is treatment naive.
So you would get a different answer in terms of the target density
depending on where you biopsy this patient's cancer.
Whereas patient two, at least for the macroscopic disease, has a uniform
somatostatin receptor expression, and we can't necessarily predict
whether they'll respond or not, but we know we will deliver high amounts of
radiation to their tumor burden.
Good discussion about beta and alpha emitters.
Betas tend to cause single-strand breaks, and so you
generally need higher activities to get effects.
Alphas tend to cause double-strand breaks, and which are
harder to repair and tend to be
harder to resist. So alpha therapies can
have better effects in radiation-resistant tumors, but also
can have higher side effect profiles.
And so some people like to favor alpha versus beta.
I think both are going to have a role and betas have a good
track record in clinical work,
as do alphas with radium-223.
In terms of theranostics in the U.S.,
radioactive iodide's been around since the '40s, so nuclear medicine theranostics
is not really new. We're just having a renaissance.
MIBG is still available for imaging.
The therapeutic I-131 version's not currently on the market,
but that has been used for neuroendocrine tumors that secrete
catecholamines.
Skeletal scintigraphy has been used to select patients who are going to get
radium-223 because radium-223 really binds to
bone matrix that's turning over, as does the MDP in this bone
scan.
But in this talk, we're going to really focus on the newer agents, somatostatin
receptor ligands, primarily for neuroendocrine tumors and PSMA
ligands for prostate cancer, which have really changed the landscape of both
diagnosis and treatment of these cancers.
I do want to remind you though, when we say theranostics in nuclear medicine, we're
often thinking, "Oh, there's a radiopharmaceutical therapy
associated with a theranostic." And while I think that's the area that's getting
the most excitement in the cancer field, appropriately so,
there are potentials for theranostics through diagnostics.
So estrogen receptor imaging with FES can
tell you whether or not there's estrogen receptor present throughout the entire
tumor burden, which at least in theory could influence decisions
about hormonal therapies. And outside of cancer, actually amyloid
PET is making a huge difference in
the diagnosis of Alzheimer's disease as well as the treatment.
So here's a patient with Alzheimer's disease.
They have a lot of cortical amyloid.
You can see that this cortical amyloid at the edge of the brain is decreased after
therapy. And so there's also roles for
theranostic nuclear medicine agents in cancer and other diseases that don't
necessarily have a radiopharmaceutical therapy associated with
them.In terms of molecular imaging for neuroendocrine tumors,
somatostatin receptor ligands are really important for the theranostic
piece. But I think something to consider in general in
theranostics and imaging is that other agents can
have a role. So FDG, the glucose analog that
shows glucose metabolism, typically has low uptake in well-differentiated
neuroendocrine tumors.
But as neuroendocrine tumors dedifferentiate and become higher grade,
they can often have more FDG uptake and actually lose their
somatostatin receptor binding. So sometimes we use
FDG to try to find disease that may be somatostatin
receptor negative. And similarly for catecholamine-secreting tumors,
MIBG still can play a role, and there's some investigational
amino acids that may play a role in certain
serotonin-secreting neuroendocrine tumors.
So in terms of dotatate therapy today, the indications are
Grade 1 or Grade 2, well-differentiated GEP-NETs,
gastroenteropancreatic neuroendocrine tumors, who progressed
on standard therapy, which is usually somatostatin analog.
And more recently, first-line therapy, so the first treatment the patient
receives for higher grade, Grade 2 and Grade 3, well-differentiated
GEP-NETs.
It is also the case that
neuroendocrine tumors, uh, and other tumors that express
somatostatin receptors like paragangliomas and meningiomas may also
be good targets for somatostatin receptor-targeted
theranostics. In terms of the toxicities that we think about when
we treat patients clinically, for almost all radionuclide
therapies, marrow toxicity is a major
consideration. And then the biodistribution of the agent
also influences organs that receive high doses.
So kidneys, and to a lesser extent, liver,
are organs we think about when we treat patients, and we follow them.
And also, particularly for dotatate, but again, when we give
therapeutic amounts of radiation, we also need to think about risk of future
malignancy. And we'll come back to that a bit, but that's a long-term
toxicity that I think we need to get a good handle on, particularly if
we start thinking about using this earlier in the treatment of patients who may
have
decades of life ahead of them.
And as with all of these
current
radiotheranostics, our goal is really to stop or slow the
growth of tumor. Right now, we're not in a place where we can cure
tumors with radiotheranostics, although hopefully in the future, I
can tick this off. So in terms of practical aspects,
our standard treatments are 200 millicuries or 7.4
gigabequerels. To put that into perspective, that's about 20
times the amount we might do for a PET scan with a shorter-lived
PET-emitting radionuclide. For alpha therapies,
particularly for longer-lived ones like radium or actinium, we're often giving
microcuries, so a thousandfold less, and that reflects
the higher biological potency of alphas versus betas.
One of the things that makes dotatate therapy a little more challenging in terms of
patient throughput is we need to give a co-infusion of
arginine and lysine amino acids. That takes about four hours,
and so patients are with us. They have to be monitored.
Occasionally, they have difficulty with the infusion.
But this really reduces the dose to the kidneys, and in the older
literature, renal toxicity was a major issue with somatostatin receptor
ligands like dotatate, but that's much, much less common now that we have this.
But it does make the administration more complicated.
If we see patients have hematologic toxicity or other toxicities,
we can delay doses. We may reduce the future dose
if the patient's able to recover from the toxicity.
And patients get somatostatin analogs during the therapy, typically.
We follow their lab values as well as their clinical status
at each cycle and in between cycles.
We expect to see some drop in blood counts with these therapies.
As long as they don't fall below dangerous levels, typically, they will
rebound and are eligible for their next cycle.
In the case of dotatate therapy for typical GEP-NETs, we're
usually imaging them at the end of therapy.
There can be pseudoprogression from tumor swelling, so we don't usually image
them during therapy, and neuroendocrine tumors that we treat
with somatostatin receptor therapies tend to be relatively slow-growing.
There are exceptions, but generally that's how this is done.
Keyvon gave a nice preview for one of the pivotal trials, NETTER-1.
This is really the one that got the Grade 1 and
2 progression patient cohorts approved.
And so you can see there's a very large progression-free survival benefit for those
getting dotatate versus high-dose somatostatin analog in NETTER-1.
In the interim analysis, there was a survival benefit.
Actually following it out, that survival benefit wasn't
seen in the final analysis. The common
reason given, which I think is plausible, is there was a lot of crossover from
control to dotatate therapy, and this was really
designed for PFS, not OS, for that reason.
More recently, the NETTER-2 trial showed that there
was a progression-free survival benefit for those receiving
dotatate therapy versus high-dose somatostatin
analog
in this higher grade, Grade 2 and 3, with KI
67 scores up to 55%. And so now this is
often a frontline treatment for these patients.
In terms of switching gears to prostate cancer, there's many agents that have been
developed. The two that are really most directly relevant to
theranostics are PSMA ligands, which I'm going to talk about,
some of which are approved, as well as bumetanide derivatives that
target GRPR. These are quite interesting because there's
differential expression of PSMA and GRPR in some tumors,
and also GRPR ligands, at least the ones that are in
advanced development, tend to undergo hepatobiliary excretion instead of
renal excretion.If we think about prostate
cancer from the time of diagnosis to progression
and then advanced stages,
imaging and more and more
nuclear medicine therapies are playing a large role.
So,
when prostate cancer is initially diagnosed confined to the prostate
gland, typically those patients will either undergo surgery or radiation
therapy with or without androgen deprivation therapy.
And many of those patients are cured, but frequently they will have a
recurrence, often picked up with PSA before serum
PSA, a blood test for prostate-specific antigen, which
allows detection of recurrence, but it doesn't tell us
where. And then these patients will typically be treated with androgen
deprivation therapy,
and will ultimately become resistant to those therapies and need either
androgen receptor pathway inhibitors or taxane-based
chemotherapy. And so in terms of imaging, active surveillance is
often done with MR,
and we are using PSMA PET for staging patients
who have a more unfavorable
risk factor for recurrence or metastases at the time of diagnosis.
Another area where PSMA PET is frequently used is
detecting and restaging patients who have biochemical recurrence,
as well as now selecting patients for potential PSMA-based
therapy.
And so now currently, radiopharmaceutical therapy with PSMA ligands
is confined to the more advanced castrate-resistant setting.
But there are trials underway that are looking to shift this
earlier. And already, as I'll come to in a moment, we've seen a shift
to earlier phase treatment in prostate cancer.
So the initial trial that was key to FDA approval was the
VISION trial, that compared PSMA 617
therapy to best standard of care, and both
in terms of progression-free survival and overall survival,
the PSMA therapy had
a survival and progression benefit.
There's also decreased skeletal events.
The benefit was about a four-month median survival benefit, so not large, but
typical of a lot of new therapies in very
advanced cancer patients. And these are really patients who had no standard of
care options. So even though four months isn't very long, it is a
substantial
change.
More recently, the PSMA 4 trial compared PSMA
617 to going to a second androgen
receptor pathway inhibitor, and showed there was better progression-free
survival, but very similar overall survival.
So there wasn't a survival benefit in this group, but
they are equivalent to switching ARPIs.
And importantly, in our experience and in trials,
generally this therapy is much easier for patients to tolerate
than other therapies, including taxanes.
And so often in patients who may have
comorbidities or just not want to do taxane therapy, we
may elect to do this over taxanes. But it's not that we have
a definite survival benefit for them.
So in terms of current indications,
the metastatic castrate-resistant prostate cancer before or after
taxane-based chemo. Again, hematologic toxicities
are the main issue. Sometimes we see renal toxicity, and
if you look at PSMA PET images, you see a lot of salivary gland
activity. Many patients have dry mouth.
With the beta emitters, that's generally been just symptomatic, but not
really affecting the patient's overall quality of life.
But they can be more severe with alpha emitters.
In terms of standard treatment, 200 millicuries is a recurring theme
currently. Hopefully, that will change as personalized dosimetry comes into play.
And we're giving these every six weeks for six total cycles.
Again, we can delay and reduce the dose if needed.
We follow their labs. And interestingly, in terms of following
response, we use serum PSA, which in most patients is a good
marker. We use imaging, as well as the patient's overall
symptoms and performance. So if patients come in with bone pain and it
improves, that's actually an important piece of information suggesting they're
responding. Many places are starting to do post-therapy
imaging. This could theoretically be done for
dosimetry, but also it can be done just as a way to
follow therapy because lutetium-177 does emit imageable
photons. And often patients will undergo an interim PET-CT,
often after the third cycle,
to see how they're doing. And this, unlike neuroendocrine tumors, kind of
reflects the more aggressive, faster growth of
prostate cancer in this setting than neuroendocrine tumors.
So here's an example of a patient we treated with PSMA therapy.
Here's their baseline PSMA PET-CT.
Lots of disease with increased activity higher than liver.
We didn't see any that was below liver that would make them ineligible.
And here's their post-therapy imaging.
And so you can see, this is just planar.
We can also do spec CT for tomographic imaging, but for simplicity, showing you
the planar. And you can see here's their PSA, and after three
cycles, this patient had a pretty dramatic response, both in terms of their
clinical
presentation. They were having pain in this arm because of the bulky
lymphadenopathy. You can see it's decreased.
Their PSA dropped, and so this was a patient who's clearly having a good
response. At the end of therapy, they look good except there's some
increased activity in this supraclavicular node, which we saw previously,
and their PSA is maybe bumped up a little.
And so this is someone who might potentially benefit
from a trial. Some people would advocate even
external beam. The imaging is playing a role in
also
their next therapy if one's available.
So some things to think about in terms of radiotheranostics for cancer.
Obviously, the target is important.
We need to be able to deliver our agent selectively or at least selectively
enough to treat the cancer and spare normal tissues.
We also need to think about the design of the radiopharmaceutical.
And when I first got involved in nuclear medicine research, I mean, this was the
area that really hooked me was you could
go after almost any target.But there are
other factors I'll talk about in a moment that I think are quite interesting.
Obviously, you want to think about what
type of cancer, what stage of cancer are you going after?
And are you targeting the tumor or the microenvironment?
So radium is an example of something that really isn't targeting the
microenvironment. It's binding to mineralized bone.
So we have clinically approved agents that are targeting the microenvironment, and
some of the up-and-coming agents also are more microenvironment than tumor
cells themselves. But beyond the target and the
ligands, things like patient selection for
therapy, as well as biomarkers that give prognosis are going to become
increasingly important, especially if we're trying to give these agents
earlier in treatment. We really want to pick the patients that are going to benefit
the most, particularly if they have other treatment options.
Pre- and post-therapy imaging and dosimetry, certainly already done
for response assessment. There's a lot of interest in
dosimetry and tailoring the dose
to the patient to give the maximum safe dose.
That has a lot of logistical challenges in practice, but
it's an important area that is of great interest.
Another thing is the amount, frequency, and duration of radiopharmaceutical
therapy. I don't want to say the current regimens are arbitrary,
but it could be that all patients may not need all
six doses of PSMA therapy.
The super responders may need fewer.
There's also the potential to give the highest
amount of activity on the first dose, because in the case of somatostatin receptor
therapy, subsequent doses actually deliver less to the tumor.
So there's a lot to be done in terms of optimizing these regimens.
Oh, I've been talking about IV administration, but there's the potential to give
these intra-arterially for meningiomas in the brain or for
neuroendocrine tumors predominantly in the liver.
And finally, combination therapies are an area where we're seeing a lot of growth.
And conceptually,
external beam radiation therapy coupled with chemotherapy, chemoradiation is
a cornerstone for many cancer therapies, and I think there's the potential
for a similar paradigm with radiopharmaceutical
therapies. So in terms of what are in the trial
landscape for radiopharmaceutical therapies, this is a fairly
recent review. So somatostatin receptors and PSMA
therapies are by far and away leading the pack with
fibroblast activation protein ligands in distant third.
But there are a number of others in development, as well as
likely more than this since this is a year old.
In terms of radionuclides, lutetium-177 leads the way with
Y90 and I-131 as the other beta emitters.
We can see actinium-225 is the most
active alpha emitter, but lead and radium are also in the mix.
Most of these are small molecules, and peptides with a few
antibodies in terms of the type of agent being used, the
vector, and not surprisingly, based on the targets, you can see that
prostate cancer and neuroendocrine tumors are the leading
target cancer types.
And so in the near future, we're going to be seeing more somatostatin
receptor ligands and PSMA ligands in clinical use.
So what do these look like? So I think actinium-225 is probably the
biggest
thing that's on the horizon,
having an alpha therapy, and this is just phase three trials, so things that are
near future, and combination therapies are also important
in these trials. For PSMA ligands, similar story,
actinium-225 ligands are in late phase development,
as well as trials looking at hormone sensitive and oligometastatic prostate
cancer. And these are being combined, again, with systemic therapies as
well as external beam radiation therapy.
Other targets, catecholamine transporters, CD20,
CD45, or at least in recent phase three trials,
as well as mineralized bone turnover radium, and sodium
iodide still around in trials. And again,
combination therapy is another feature of these trials.
Another
thing we'd really like to be able to do is predict who's going to respond,
either before starting or early during therapy.
And this is going to be really important when other therapeutic options are
available. This really wasn't the case with the initial dodetate and
PSMA therapies. There really weren't other options.
But as we tried to move earlier, we really need to be able to select those patients
who are going to benefit. So presence and amount of target, total tumor volume,
imaging biomarkers, response assessment during therapy, and genomics are
important. So this is from the therapy trial conducted in
Australia, where they showed higher PSMA
ligand uptake with PET, SUV mean over 10, had
much better response in terms of PSA response than if you
had PSMA uptake lower than 10. So higher uptake on
PET predicted responders in this study.
Similarly, those who had high FDG tumor volume, so
lots of aerobic glycolysis, had a worse outcome for
both taxane-based and PSMA-based therapy.
They also used cell ctDNA, circulating tumor
DNA, in these studies, and
not surprisingly, they found lower amounts of circulating tumor
DNA predicted better response in terms of progression-free
survival and overall survival for both PSMA
and taxane-based therapies. And they also found that
PTEN alterations were associated with worse
PFS and OS with cabazitaxel,
and ATM defects, so defects in DNA repair,
were also predicted favorable
response with PSMA therapy. Not surprisingly that
defects in DNA repair might make these more
effective.In terms of imaging during
therapy there's also data from University of Washington and
the Hutch that new lesions seen
on second or third cycle after
PSMA PET therapy, this is post-therapy imaging like I showed you,
predicts
if you have new lesions you have much worse survival here in green
and, sorry, progression-free survival and overall survival than those that did
not. And similarly, higher tumor volumes also predicted worse
outcomes.
So, another aspect is applying radiopharmaceutical therapy
to patients based on target expression and not so much
histology.
This may be an
option when patients don't have good standard of care therapies.
Gathering data that's really
convincing is challenging, as is reimbursement.
And so here's an example from our institution with a patient who had a
metastatic, at least in the CNS, pineocytoma, not a
very common tumor at all. But they did have somatostatin receptor expression
on histology, and they were having worsening lower extremity weakness.
You can see the uptake along the spinal cord from the metastases.
And here they were prior to therapy.
These white dots are leptomeningeal spread of
tumor that substantially improved after three cycles of therapy.
And so I don't think there's ever going to be a pineocytoma clinical trial,
but I think the idea of acting on the target rather than
histology is something available to this therapy.
There's similar trials underway for meningiomas, which often express a lot of
somatostatin receptors.
Combination trials with PARP inhibitors,
the idea of inhibiting DNA repair to augment
the effect of radiopharmaceuticals is quite intriguing and at
least initial studies suggest safety.
Similar story with immune checkpoint inhibitors, which I think is a really
promising area of combination therapy.
I think predicting long-term toxicities is going to be very important,
especially if we have patients who might live a long time.
A patient with metastatic castrate resistant prostate cancer is very different than
a man with biochemically recurrent prostate cancer.
And so the long-term toxicities at biochemical recurrence are much more
important than someone with very advanced prostate cancer.
There's not a lot of data out there right now, and this is an area kind of ripe for
development. I think for the sake of time, I'm just going to skip to the end and
just give you my conclusions. So somatostatin receptor and PSMA therapies are
the most actively investigated targets for radiopharmaceutical therapy in
clinical trials. And so although
we're really excited by new ligands for new targets, these are very important
too. There's a lot more to be done and understood with our existing agents.
Large data sets from their clinical use and large clinical
trials are going to give us more information and help expand their use and
efficacy. Many of the approaches that we apply to
radiopharmaceutical therapies are relevant to emerging
investigational radiopharmaceutical therapies and hopefully it's obvious, but
we really need high quality clinical trials needed to shift clinical practice
and foster the adoption of radiopharmaceutical
approaches. So those phase three trials are the language of oncologists, and that's
what gets them excited to use these for their patients.
So with that, I'll stop. I appreciate your attention, and I think we're going to
now have our round table, correct? Great.
That was great.
Thank you so much. So for the purpose of the round table,
Julia, I wanted to invite you to come up to join us.
So you can sit over there. And then,
if you would like to ask a question, please use the mics on the side of the
room. The session's being streamed, and so that provides an
ability for the streamers to also be part of the session.
While we're waiting for the first questions, I wanted to start with maybe
something pseudo-provocative, something that I personally have been
debating with others for quite a long time, which is,
what intuition do you have,
and maybe first for John, is it really
about receptor expression
when we
kind of inform dose or is it about size?
It just seems so binary. You express the target and then all of the
indicators really are, do I have another tumor after therapy, therefore, maybe it
doesn't respond or
the receptor is not relevant. So,
what do you think about that?
So I have an opinion. Oh, sorry about that.
I have an opinion, not data. I think
it's going to depend a little bit on the cancer and the biology.
I think with combination therapies, it also may be different than with
radionuclide monotherapies.
Clearly with PSMA, there is a relationship between
uptake and response, but I don't think it's simple.
And I know anecdotally, we've seen patients with very high uptake
not respond. On some trials, we've seen some of our patients with
lowest uptake get the best response.
And so I do think it's overly simplistic to think
all it is about is about radiation delivery.
It is clear from external beam therapy and as well as
some of the radiopharmaceutical therapy data that in general, higher amounts
delivered to the tumor are important. But I don't think it's that simple.
And there's provocative data about immune system
activation that heterogeneous delivery may be better
than homogenous delivery. So I do think it's
important, but it's just one parameter.
Yes, go ahead.
I don't know if that's on.
It should be on the top probably.
Let me take care of it.
Okay.
If you yell, then I will repeat it.
My question is about indications beyond NET
and prostate cancer. So
where do you see the next wave coming of therapies in
solid tumors beyond everybody piling into
prostate and GEP-NET?
I'm going to jump in there and say we have another session, is it on Monday?
Mm-hmm.
That's talking exactly about that. What's next? What's coming next?
With lessons learned from the PSMA and the neuroendocrine, where
next?
I personally, I'm going to say it out loud, women's health needs to be a focus as
well. We have a lot in prostate,
and we have a lot of solid target tumors that we can go after.
Do you remember the time on Monday?
On the 20th.
Yeah.
April 20th.
Yeah. Thanks for the great talk. Frank Li from WhichAptak.
So one thing I'm very interested in too, you are talking about
radiopharmaceutical combination chemotherapies.
That's
still by far the very best cancer treatment,
right? So compared to even all the new modalities.
But
why don't we just combine with ADCs, right?
ADC, I think it is like a
targeted therapy. It's targeting
chemotherapy, right?
It's good.
Like a
radiopharmaceutical give better data, but
better outcome, right?
I think it's a reasonable approach.
And there are
companies developing CAR T-cells for these targets and other like PSMA
ligands that are not a radioactive payload.
I do think there's a place for that as well.
Ultimately, you need trial data to show these
work. I do think one of the advantages of radiopharmaceutical
therapy, at least for the approved agents, is the toxicities tend to
be lower than a lot of conventional therapies.
That's not across the board. We have patients who have severe toxicities.
That does happen.
But I do think the safety profile, at least at the dosages we're using,
are quite good. But your point's well taken.
There are other ways to target these
cancer targets. That's not an unreasonable approach.
Another question. Alpha or beta, right?
So why do people always use beta or alpha?
Because from your list, like PSMA, they both have alpha
and beta, right? So the beta,
what's the different effect?
Yeah, and others too, feel free to chime in.
I think there's room for both.
It is definitely the case that there are small studies that have shown alphas can
work where the same ligand or similar ligand,
patient progressed. But the toxicities can
be much higher with the alphas. And I don't think it's
necessarily a night and day difference.
So I think that's an area for a lot of investigation.
I actually think it may be that for certain things like immune
therapy,
it's possible that an alpha versus a beta might
differentially engage the immune system.
But I don't think it's clear that alphas are better or that betas are better.
I don't know.
Oh, no. So they look promising, but in terms of a direct head-to-head
comparison in
a large randomized controlled trial, we don't have that kind of data.
I
just don't think it's as simple as which one is better.
It is clear that alphas can work in patients who've
progressed after betas, but I don't think
there's enough data to say that means we should do alphas.
The trial hasn't been done yet.
Before you ask, just to follow up with that because there's a couple of questions
online that are kind of in a similar range, is that do you have an
expectation for smaller tumors
responding better to, let's say, an alpha versus a beta emitter?
Is there any intuition based on maybe the path length of the
delivered dose that would suggest maybe
smaller tumors could respond better to one isotope versus another?
Yeah, that thing is loud.
Yeah. There we go.
That one's dangerous.
You have any questions online, I'll just rattle it.
Is that on?
There has been things that show that for alpha and even conversion
electrons, they work better for smaller tumors than the betas
because of the amount of dose that actually gets delivered.
And going back to the alpha versus beta,
there's a group actually in Oxford who's been looking
at both alpha and betas. And
they've seen that although you would tend to think that
maybe alphas are the way to go, that there are certain
tumors that actually respond better with betas than alphas.
But overall, what they're showing is that your best bet is to hit
them hard initially and then to use something that gives them a slow
burn. The challenge, though, is I don't know how you actually do that
with clinical trials in which you have to always show it against the standard of
care.
So right now, I think physicians are like, "Well, we're going to use the betas
first because that's what's there, and then we'll follow up with the
alphas." But I don't know how you ever get alphas to the point that you could
actually try it earlier first, where you might have a better
impact
There's so many data points that are coming together.
I think that it is possible to get the significant safety profile.
Shift everyone to a
class, PFS plus six, no OS benefit.
Not optimal oncology. You see the class from PSMA targeting came
in Neter1 or
4F becomes PSMA focal, PFS plus six, no OS benefit,
and that class is not allowed crossover in Europe because
ubichitin
is not a regulated indicator yet. James has an Adasmo, another class from NCI
Canada with a systematic crossover after PSMA ubichitin and then
crossover after their Shaparoval survival 1.2.
Is there something about your pharmaceuticals that's interfering with the
ability to get subsequent treatment?
That's why they're taking away OS benefits.
Is another hindrance, are you thinking that dose is wrong?
Different combination of targeting modules could make
a difference.
So I think that's a great question.
I don't have a perfect answer to you.
I think for the NETs, I think PFS was a reasonable
endpoint. I do think that your point is well taken
that for the pre-taxane
PSMA therapy setting, there really isn't
a clear rationale to give. The only thing I
would say is just anecdotally, we have found patients often tolerate it
better than taxanes, and so often we
pick older or frailer patients to get
PSMA therapy. But your point's well taken.
I
guess the way I think about it is these are just another cancer treatment.
They're not magic bullets. They're not incredibly special.
I think we need more data and long-term follow-up to understand their
role.
And I think that's especially true when patients have other
options. When we're talking about especially Neter1
and frankly Neter2, there's not a great systemic option.
There are options. But as we try to move
PSMA therapy back, I think that question becomes very important.
Whether we're closing the door to future therapies, I don't think we know that
based on at least the large trials, but it is a question.
And the marrow toxicity and long-term toxicities are
probably more similar to other
chemotherapies than the initial
acute toxicities, which tend to be less.
I'm not sure I've answered your question, but I think it's important to keep in
mind. These are just another cancer treatment.
We can't think of them as
something beyond other treatments, but I do think the trial
data, at least for the approved indications, do support their use.
Maybe following that question, I think there is an underlying, which is in a
number of the questions that come online and also this thought process.
With the intuition from external beam therapy
and the idea of extremely high dose, like what you would
call flash therapy for cure,
is there a place where maybe we're not delivering
enough dose
for cure? And is that
the real reason why overall survival benefit isn't as strong?
Is it that we're just not blasting these tumors enough
or because of
other tissue damage? Or do we think it's
not actually about the dose?
Do you think it's about the stage at which these patients are getting the dose?
That they can't handle the dose that could cure them.
Yeah.
And I would say at least these patients don't have a curative option for anything.
And so I think that's one of the other challenges.
We're using these in,
I think, appropriately advanced metastatic settings.
And one of the questions about type of radiation versus tumor
size. For neuroendocrine tumors, it is the case that
people with smaller metastatic burdens in the liver, for example,
have better responses to dotatate therapy.
But the problem is, I think you have the confound of people with higher
tumor burdens just don't do as well as people who have lower tumor
burdens. And so
doing a trial that gets rid of that confound,
I think you'd have to do, because in general, more tumor is worse.
Like the size.
Yeah.
I have a question related to toxicity.
So usually for radioligand therapies, for smaller compounds
or VHH, we see kidney uptake and kidney toxicity,
and for
full size antibody or antibody fragments, we see liver uptake and liver toxicity.
Let's say if there is a new exciting target and people are
developing new radioligand therapies for this
target, and if they have to make a choice between
kidney toxicity or liver toxicity, what's your comment?
So,
what I would say is this.
I would think about the type of cancer and the type of organ dysfunction that's
more likely to occur. So in
prostate cancer, sometimes people have obstruction.
They're often, not always, but often older.
So, I think having an option with hepatobiliary excretion, like
GRPR ligands, is really interesting and important.
In clinical practice, at least with the approved agents,
I find hematologic toxicity, so low platelets, low
neutrophil counts, are usually the things that
stop therapy rather than other organ toxicity.
Now, that doesn't mean we don't have renal toxicity.
That does happen, or liver toxicity.
Liver also,
I think, is a little more radio resistant and can take
more of a hit. So, I think there is an advantage to hepatobiliary
excretion as well. But it would depend a little bit
on what kind ofOrgan dysfunction is most common
in the patient population you're treating.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for the interesting talks.
So my question is
about stromal versus cellular targets.
So you see most of the trials, as well as the success, mainly for
somatostatin receptor targeting and prostate.
So these are cellular targets. When it comes to stromal targets such
as FAP, for example, which is a pan-tumor target, you can really see high
tumor uptake. Why do you think the therapeutic
success has not been seen? Is it due to the spatial
separation of the radiation dose?
Or what could be the future of stromal targeting for radioligand
therapy and also other modalities?
I think so far it's been the retention, hasn't it, that's been the challenge with
these FAP agents. I have a little bias because I've got a cell surface target I'm
very interested in, so you can take that with a grain of salt, but.
It's a fair question. There are small published studies showing some
efficacy, so there can be some efficacy.
But I think one concern is just the dose delivered to the tumor
high enough, not so much,
which has to do with retention and so maybe with different targeting, that
can be improved. I do think there is the potential for
combination therapy, which is really exciting with these
less cancer-specific targets like
FAP. There are trials underway looking at
combination therapies with FAP ligands, and I
do think that is an area where we'll have to see, but potentially, if
you really think cancer-associated fibroblasts are playing a
detrimental role and could increase either delivery of a
chemotherapy or take away some of the immune
inhibition from CAFs, that might be a place
where you might see a lot of benefit.
And the appeal is that you could potentially treat a
lot of different tumors with the same target.
Thank you.
I'm just wondering whether there's ever any role for the
use of external beam radiation
in view of the heterogeneity and sometimes the lack of target expression
in one metastasis and not in the others.
Mm-hmm.
So, that's a really provocative and interesting question.
And in fact, there's been some, this is more CNS disease,
but combining radiopharmaceutical therapy
administered intravenously with external beam to kind of boost the dose.
I do think there's also, it's something we
have done in our practice, more on a palliative basis, not really treatment
of if we see that the overall tumor burden's
responding, but there's some symptomatic
pathological fractures, treating those.
I think that's an interesting and rational approach, but I don't
think we have data to guide us. But I do think that's an interesting idea.
Thanks for the great talk. I have a question for
terbium, actually.
So we all know that terbium actually right now have a couple of
clinical trials starting right now.
But based upon the characteristics between the terbium and the lutetium, if I'm not
wrong,
I think in terms of the beta energy, kind of very
similar, the
half-life is very similar. The only new features that
terbium has is the auger electrons that actually
being a little bit high energy, but at the same time shorter
range, not like the beta. What do you guys
think about the
benefits of those,
the auger electron brings into the
therapy-wise, and also the same time, is that really
something that we want to pay? Because the terbium
generation is very expensive and also we do not
have a very productive
way to generate larger quantity. So there's a major
benefit, we want to pay off that?
Thanks.
I think that's another thing that depends on your molecule, right?
So the added benefit is if your molecule's internalized,
then you're going to get the added power of the terbium.
If it's cell surface and not internalized, then it's probably going to
behave very similarly to the lutetium.
So it's not one's better than the other, it's what you're putting out and what
molecule it's going onto.
Maybe not even just internalized, maybe nuclear.
You need to get it much closer to DNA for it to matter.
So the benefit is going to scale to where it localizes in a
cell, too.
Last thing I'd just say, it's always the case with novel
radioisotopes, the supply chain's an issue.
When I was getting started, copper-64 was exotic.
It was very limited availability, and now it's in
commercial products. So, I think your point's well taken.
Is it worth doing? I think we don't know, but I would say,
the work we're doing now is built on decades of people
optimizing these
methods. But yeah, I don't know if terbium will make it or not.
Oh, wow. It's loud. I was curious to hear
all of your thoughts on
leveraging blood liquid biopsies to
select patients and also to monitor patients.
And the specific area I'm looking at is circulating tumor cells because that
technology has really evolved over the past several years, and now you
can consistently capture a lot of cells that
were not known before.
So I'm thinking, so there are two questions.
One is,
do you guys envision using that as a
pre-screenTo say, "Hey,
PSMA positive. If you're CTC positive, then you go on
imaging,"
and that'll make it more scalable.
Especially when the target prevalence is low, it doesn't make
sense to screen 100 patients only to find 10 with PET scans,
right? So CTC is a simple blood draw.
And the second thing is the understanding why someone is not responding.
You can look at 15, 20 proteins at single-cell levels now.
You can do RNA and DNA analysis.
Is that something you guys are thinking about integrating into
radioligand therapies?
So,
I think it's a great question. I think one of the major
bottlenecks for this field in general is throughput to be able to
get how do you select the right patients that would benefit?
And right now, maybe one major hurdle is the imaging, actually,
and that if you could use things like circulating DNA where you decouple
that screening from actually treatment, it would be, I think, a
massive gain for the field in terms of selecting patients.
I think the challenge is if the major response
criterion is a burden, size, and where, and
trying to find the non-responder, I think ultimately it will come
back to the imaging. I think the circulating DNA maybe will help on the front end,
but I think it'll be challenging for response monitoring.
But it is a fantastic front end, and I think a lot of
people are actually-- And it was in the last couple of trials,
actually, circulating tumor DNA was in there.
If it's true, kind of what we were originally talking about, that maybe
qualifying you for therapy is almost binary.
Do you have any significant expression?
Then circulating TNA may even get you to that, too.
Can I ask a follow-up? Sorry.
Sure.
I was referring to more--
ctDNA is one, but it-
Yeah, circulating cells.
Cells, because now you can detect protein expression, whereas ctDNA,
you can't analyze protein expression.
Sure.
Yeah. I think one of the things that we would like to be able to tell our
patients is more definitely are you likely to respond.
We can say we're going to deliver radiation based on the imaging, but
we don't necessarily know a lot more.
So yeah, I think there is a huge role for all sorts of
prognostic markers. And now that these are, especially
for PSMA therapies, now that they're widely done, there are
enough patients where if you could gather this in a
systematic way, you could test that.
I
don't know if the pharmaceutical company is going to do this, but actually
cooperative trial groups are starting to look at this, and that's something
that I think is doable and not incredibly expensive and
very important.
Okay. So you quickly touched upon that, about
regimen of administration. It seemed like every six weeks for lutetium
agent was more driven by when lutetium was available
versus any biology. So how will you define an optimal
regimen? Would it be based on radionuclide half-life, target
occupancy, or more safety and recovery of potential AEs?
So maybe, kind of to build on your question, it's more of a general thing, which I
think is a theme throughout all of this, is that how do you model
how to dose these patients? Why do they get an average
of five cycles of XYZ 200
millicurie?
How do we make it more personalized
or better performing?
So I do think hematologic recovery is one aspect.
And you
could go even sooner than four weeks.
There's no reason you couldn't, but usually it takes a week
or two weeks to really see people who are going to recover, see
them nadir and then come up. So you might have
concerns about doing it
more frequently than three to four weeks. But they are arbitrary.
That is an area where I think even though it's maybe not as exciting as a
new target, I don't think we have the answer.
I think the challenge is really doing a trial that proves it makes a
difference. That's an expensive trial for maybe not a
lot of advantage, and that's one of the challenges is how do you gather the
data for things that may not have big
differences. It is the case for somatostatin receptor therapy that it does
look like the first administration delivers the highest dose
to the tumor. And so I think that is another way we may see the dosing
more upfront rather than equally divided.
So just for the sake of time, because I think we're over, they're going to kick us
out of the room. Please stick around. You can talk to the panel afterwards.
I just wanted to remind you that we have this special
AACR-sponsored conference, which will happen in January.
If you're interested, the QR code is on the big
screen. And I know a number of the questions that were online
actually would be responded to if you come to this meeting.
So
you should come to our meeting and please attend the other sessions
throughout the rest of AACR. So thank you so much, and thank the speakers